i'm on  the 81st floor in the south tower  what i saw was a tiny little speck of a  plane  it's getting larger and larger and  larger  [Music]  oh my god and it was 30 people in the  northeast corner  i ran through three flights of stairs  that were on fire  i had burns on 60 of my body  but i was alive  many people ask me what was it like that  day  there were signs of devastation  everywhere  still around guys still around  but there were also signs of hope  those little moments of caring for  another were the difference between life  and death you had an every transmission  by saying  i'm coming for you brother i'm coming  for you  this is your mother just your father  this is a human being i felt compelled  to respond he said mom i just want to  tell you i love you  that's how you want people to remember  you if we die we die with them  nobody's leaving you i'm gonna live  you